every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without my name is Joshua fields
Milburn and that makes us the
minimalists and we're here to answer
your questions today we're gonna start
off I don't know how much time we have
so we're gonna start with three
questions the first three people who
ever want to come up and and ask your
question on this microphone we'll be
happy to answer them the good news is my
favorite pedagogical technique is if I
don't have an answer to your question I
will just ask a or I'll answer a
different question so you can ask
whatever you want just say your name and
whatever your question is all right hi
guys my name is George and first of all
keep doing the great work that you're
doing keep spreading the word so I've
got a multi-part question and then maybe
a shameless plug at the end first of all
I mean Ryan your your hair is definitely
minimalist yours Josh I don't know how
you keep your products down you know the
hair product I think you're lying to us
on that now it's just the wig it's one
of my 50 items that I own excellent
second I look at you guys and and what
really stands out most is not the hair
it's actually the shoes the shoes so
where where do you get those shoes
they're awesome
there were in the video as well yeah
yeah this is not a great answer but eBay
I mean I tend to buy a lot of used stuff
and yeah just eBay man you want to know
about my my kind of shoes well yeah yeah
these are um actually Josh got these and
tried them out and didn't like them and
we have the same exact foot size believe
it or not and like the way you get there
called seer issues it spelled with an X
this is not an advertisement by the way
um but you you actually trace your foot
out fax it in and then they make the
shoe for you
so I mean literally like I have my
accident he had the buy a fax machine
from eBay you just outed yourself but
yeah like you scan them and then email
them in fax it's so funny man that makes
did I'm old man but yeah he just so
happens like we both have like the same
like my left foot is the smaller of the
two is the same but yeah I'm like dude
I'll totally try this out because I was
wearing Tom's for a while um but my feet
sweat really bad and like these are
really cool cuz like I can think it's
what as much as they won their out nice
but now I love them and they're uh
they're really comforting them sometimes
they're great so I've got a question
about the future saw you guys well you
wrote a book I saw you when you were
here for the book tour now you have a
documentary thanks and I'm here again
and I'm really curious to know what am I
going to be at next you know what's
what's next for the minimalists what's
next
yeah the minimalists theme park there be
one ride
but it's a really awesome ride a very
deliberate ride yeah we so I'll tell you
this I was talking about earlier about
being busy right we're all very busy I
I've gotten really good over the last
six years or so at saying no and I
realized that for the longest time the
reason I was so busy was because I said
yes to way too many things and I was
saying yes so much there's an old a
Pathan that you know if you want to get
something done give it to a busy person
because the busy person tends to be the
most sort of productive and there will
intake just about everything on right
for me I've gotten good at saying no to
a lot of the requests that we have so I
can say yes to what's most important and
give you an example Ryan and I tend to
focus on one thing a year and everything
else tends to lead to that thing or
serves that thing in some way so this
year 2016
it's the documentary and everything else
that we're doing serves that in some way
whether it's the podcast which lets more
people know about it but also adds value
in a different way whether it's this
tour which which I mean we don't
necessarily have to do but what we'd
love to do is get out in front of people
and interact with them see what you know
what they find value in and so we will
focus on one thing a year and I don't
look much farther than the next year so
we have a few ideas for 2017 possibly a
TV show online and and some other things
that I can't talk about just yet but we
have a few ideas whatever it is we'll be
really intentional about it and
everything else we do will stay focused
on that my favorite quote I talked about
a little bit in the movie is from Henry
David Thoreau he said it's not enough to
be busy the question is what are you
busy about and if I were to append that
I would say what are you focused on and
for us our very first book that we wrote
was a book called minimalism live a
meaningful life
and we in that book we wrote about the
the five higher-order values health
relationships passion growth
contribution and and I've learned that
for me if I'm ever feeling unfulfilled
in life it's because I'm not focused on
one of those five areas and so anything
we do anything we focus on needs to
serve needs to allow me to focus on
those areas of my own life but also
contribute to the to the greater good
it's what we were just talking about
this actually I'm like man we get I'll
give you a little teaser something we're
getting ready to do when we get back we
have a TEDx another TEDx talk that we're
working on has anyone see the TEDx talk
yep cool yeah so you know how like it
was me talking the whole time and Josh
is doing so it's gonna be like the
obverse where he'll be doing most of the
talking then I'll be the the one in the
background but we've got that to kind of
plan for in practice but yeah just to
Josh's point we we do focus on on one
thing every year and we do make sure
that that is deliberate we have you know
plenty of books book ideas we have you
know this web series that we're talking
about doing we have our podcasts so
there's certainly a lot of options for
us but yeah we haven't necessarily like
nailed down exactly what we're gonna do
for 2017 last thing I see a lot of faces
here and I don't know if anybody
everybody knows us but there is the
minimalist local group and my buddy
Charles back there you wave Charles
Charles leads the local group for you
guys so it's kind of a shameless plug
for you so so let's talk about thank you
for bringing that up George I appreciate
it oh you a dollar you know we in 2014
we went out on the road we we donated a
year of our lives basically it's really
expensive to go out in the tour and and
you and try to really spread something
we believe in not proselytize not
convert people to my same belief system
but just share something that I think
other people can get some sort of value
in a recipe that a few people can tweeze
ingredients from and so we show up in a
city and prior to the 2014 to
we had much smaller tours and people say
it's you know it's cool you guys are
here for a day but now you're leaving
how can i connect with open-minded
like-minded people here locally and I'd
always say I don't know OkCupid is the
thing I don't really know and and that's
why in 2014 we set up a website called
minimalist org and the 100 cities we
went to over the course of ten months
and eight different countries we
basically just left behind a meetup
group we don't want anything from anyone
we don't ask for money or email
addresses or anything like that but if
you're interested in connecting with
open minded supportive people locally I
think it's a great place to start and
it's not just about decluttering or
minimalism it can be about careers or
relationships or or whatever Harry here
what's that just having a beer sometime
yeah yes sometimes it's just talking and
getting to know someone and finding out
how you can support them as well I mean
every good relationship is is I'm going
to get something from it but I'm also
going to give to it and I've learned
that it's probably the biggest thing
I've learned over the last six years is
a lesson my friend taught me a long time
ago you can't change the people around
you but you can change the people around
you and what I mean by that is you can't
you can't try to change someone your
life I'm gonna make you be like this
how can I make my husband daughter wife
spouse whoever be a minimalist well you
can't change the person but you can
surround yourself with supportive people
that help you change into the best
version of yourself and often when you
do that the people in your life that you
initially wanted to change those people
that they come into the fold with you
because they see the benefits they see
the why not the how and so I found that
surrounding myself with supportive
people was one of the best things I
could do to live a better life and to be
the best version of myself so yeah if
you're interested the I'm sure you can
you can connect here but you can also go
to minimalist org and
and find the the meetup group there and
they post stuff online as well so
articles tips all kinds of stuff yeah
it's definitely great for the Miami
crowd and I'm from up north from Fort
Lauderdale so we just recently started
the Broward minimalist movement I
started that I so nice if you're up in
Broward and don't want to drive all the
way down here you know please come up
and join us join the you can find it on
Facebook Broward mentalist movement and
if not you know we we also come down and
join Charles and we do stuff together so
it's great it's beautiful thanks George
thank you she had a brother howdy my
name is Dori
Wade before the Bluefish and I'd like to
say hi to my favorite men on the list
Lindsey and Dan they gave everything and
they're in big William a RV thing and I
you've led into what I wanted to ask
about it was about sharing the message
and I understand I can share websites
and and links and in your film and
things like that but I know the best way
is to be the example but before I get to
that end point I've tried to share
messages before you know from recycling
to volunteering to voting whatever it
might be and there's kind of a shutdown
where they don't want to hear that and
you guys have explained in many ways but
do you have another way for me to share
this message I think so so first off I
would discourage anyone from jumping up
and saying look at me I'm a minimalist I
mean it can you imagine if flashback the
screen gets fuzzy here and it's 2009 and
I've got my tie on and I Shelby and I
say hey Ryan I'm a minimalist and you
should be too because you've got a lot
of crap
how do you think you would have reacted
to that yeah I definitely would not have
been as open to to what you had to say
cuz I would have felt judged I would
have felt like what do you mean I got of
course I got like crap like much money I
make yeah why wouldn't I have a lot of
crap I mean that's probably I would have
reacted right and and so instead of me
going out trying to sell this idea
eventually when Ryan came to me it was
eight months after I had simplified my
life or been simplifying my life I
hadn't reached an end point that was a
word you use there before I reach this
end point I still haven't reached an end
point and that feels good to realize
that I'm never going to get there and
and so Ryan came in one day and said why
the hell are you so happy it's because
he saw the benefits so my mom had died
my marriage had ended but I was still
working in the corporate world 70 80
hours a week but something had changed I
it's not that I was happy relative to
what I am now I'm far happier now but I
had stopped chasing happiness I realized
that happiness isn't the point
and the more we chase happiness the
farther away we're gonna get from it see
what the point of all of this was it was
living a more meaningful life and
defining what that means see when I was
successful in a very narrow sense I was
successful monetarily and I had a job
title that may have impressed a few
dozen people but the truth is I wasn't
successful in the broader sense and and
so by by changing my definition of
success I was no longer chasing the
happiness through the next paycheck the
next promotion the next purchase I was
able to learn that the a meaningful life
would make me happy happiness was simply
a byproduct of living in accordance with
my values and and to get there I had to
figure out what my values were I was
focused on the wrong stuff
I wasn't focused on what was important
to me I didn't even know what was
important anymore I got to that point
where it's like okay happiness is right
around the bin and then you get around
the bend the right around the corner and
there's another corner you're like oh
it's gonna be around that corner and
then you never get there and it's like
well wait a minute what am I focused on
I need to stop trying to worry about
being happy and start worrying about
what is important in my life and so I
say yeah yes at that example but I'll
also say this about about the
documentary the the reason that we
really wanted to make this film is what
I said earlier during the intro is we
wanted to find a way to make minimalism
more accessible because it has for
awhile been the Josh and Ryan show and
we've we've shown a bunch of other
minimalist in other ways we could but
this was the way for us to say look at
all these other recipes you have Leo Bob
Alta in there with six kids and he puts
us to shame he washes his t-shirts in
the sinks though and that wasn't the
lifestyle I wanted to live but I admired
that you also had Colin right in there
he travels to a new country every four
months again not a life I wanted to live
but I admired that it allowed him to
pursue what was important to him and so
I think the documentary is will be a
great thing to share with people but
ultimately you're right the best way to
show the change is to show the change
yeah I just want to speak to his point
of proselytizing I was a Jehovah's
Witness for like 24 years knocking on
doors for 24 years you know how many
people I converted 0 now 1 and with this
journey of minimalism
I haven't knocked on one person's door I
have never forward it or like sent
someone in this advert and said you've
got to read this because you this would
help you we simply started a website and
told our story with no expectation and
people found value in it and ultimately
I would I would you know it
you to kind of transfer that to to your
life meaning you know if you see someone
who is complaining about oh man you know
way too much stuff I don't know how to
declutter I hold on to all this just in
case stuff for example you might say oh
you know the minimalistic they wrote an
essay about just in case stuff you might
like it I mean something that speaks to
something that they're already calling
out that they have a problem with but
but yeah certainly you know if you have
a friend who you feel like is a hoarder
and you send them our website they mean
they might very well take offense to
that like who are you to tell me I got
too much stuff so I would look for
little opportunities like that but but
ultimately it is it is living by example
when I saw Josh you know like he moved
him and his wife split up and I'm
helping to move into his new apartment
and he's got this lake nice TV bracket
on the wall that came with the apartment
and like the first thing I thought was
like oh I wonder how think of a TV he's
gonna get this is like a big thing
between us we were always like hey look
at my TV you know look at my TV look at
my three TVs and six months would mark a
couple months my by and I'm like you
know over at his apartment are gonna get
a TV I may or may not six months goes by
still no TV I noticed how he was acting
different at work he started setting
expectations with our boss like hey I'm
gonna be available from 7:00 a.m. until
8:00 p.m. and that's it and that that's
a lot of hours to give you and which was
like sacrilegious were we were working
at we were on-call like doctors except
we worked in retail we weren't saving
anybody
we couldn't even save ourselves yeah so
when I saw those things that's what
really made me say okay josh is doing
something that is making him not just
happier but I saw him regaining control
of his time and and and really doing
good things with his focus and that's
what made me go to him be like dude
what's going on with you why the hell
are you so happy lately so keep up the
good work and that's that's what we can
encourage you to do thank you
what am I supposed to say when I get so
your name okay look for question is
Quentin my name is Quentin I'm from
Miami and I didn't realize you had shoes
on I thought you were barefooted the
whole time so so you guys sort of
alluded to to the to some of the answers
to my question prior to meeting up here
with the gentleman and the young lady I
just left but my question was I live
with a maxim of this wife and and three
max the mother's children and and you
know so I I can't check I can't change
it but I don't I don't want to I love my
shoe and I love my wife so so that's not
an that's not an option for me
but you sort of alluded it you alluded
to it but maybe if you can expand on it
a little bit huh you know I tried the
the blunt-force trama method and you
just like got rid of her stuff without
telling them yeah don't do that well
actually it worked until that because we
have so much stuff that the kids didn't
even notice the stuff was missing yeah
and and my wife has so much clothes
literally she didn't notice the stuff
was missing she has a G she has a drawer
she has what do you call those things a
dresser I think so yeah the dresser
would she I went through when I counted
on one time I think it was about 2000
tops that she has so I got rid of about
how many I think it was about 2000 oh
wow but then I just started guessing I
said okay this big it must be about so
it's not an accurate count but but
roughly two thousand so I I got rid of
some stuff and she need even know I got
rid of it
and then you know I like I said I did
the Java witness thing so I said hey you
know I'm watching these videos I you
know and she she's just totally not not
into it at all and and and she didn't
even want to come no I'm not coming so
so so I guess my question is you know
how do you yeah man you know you love
your wife you love your kids man I mean
really ultimately all you can do is
support a man I mean it telling them
that they're wrong or forcing our books
or essays on them or this movie on them
it's gonna have an obvious effect I mean
think about like if you're talking to
someone about their religion and and
you're very clear on like why they're
you know their their religion is is not
correct or their political view or you
know insert you know hi tense subject
there when you when you when I know when
I used to get combative with people over
that those types of things or they would
get combative with me it just made me
hold on to my beliefs even more and the
same thing if I was you know being
combative with someone out that it just
kind of strengthens the way that they
feel so the only way to kind of move
them along which what I've seen like
like with my mom for example you know
she uh she called me up like a month
after the we had launched the website
and she's like hey son how you doing I'm
good mom how are you doing
she's like I'm great what's this
minimalist crap I was like oh you found
the website like we hadn't told anyone
she was googling my name she must have
been found it she's like what does this
mean like what are you depressed are you
are you not gonna be around for holidays
anymore
can i buy you stuff like I still buy you
gifts remember she asked you if you're
gonna if you're if you're becoming a
monk
yeah she she didn't really know what to
make of it so I'm like yeah yes mom I am
depressed actually um and I'm really
trying to change that I'm trying to get
out of this rut and I'm trying to live
my life differently to get out of this
rut and mom I will totally be around for
holidays in fact I hope to be around
more than just holidays because that's
about all all I ever saw her was during
holidays Mother's Day birthday like just
just those important days and she lived
a half hour away from me like I I knew I
should have been seeing her more about I
was so busy that I I just I put that off
and I'm like no I really hope I can be
around more and I really hope that I can
really develop a better relationship
with you and I said but yeah when it
comes to buying me gifts I would
appreciate it if you wouldn't get me
anything I I really am trying to be
deliberate with the physical possessions
and are bringing into my life and and
yeah please don't buy me anything she
was like well really proud of you that's
great glad you're changing your life but
I'm Your Mother and I'm still gonna buy
his stuff and I suppose she has the
right to say that as my mom um I was
like well I was kind of taken back like
that did not go how I expected I was
like well mom to be honest with you if
you gave me something and I can't use it
I'm gonna have to find a friend to give
it to or I'm gonna have to donate it I'm
gonna have to get rid of it that is not
the thing to say to your mom by the way
um and she got she got pretty defensive
and we were kind of going back and forth
and eventually I just kind of stopped
her I'm like mom you know I just love
you so much
you love me right she's like of course I
love you son I'm like I want you to be
happy I really want you to be happy you
want me to be happy too right
she's like yeah of course I want you to
be happy I'm like well mom if that's the
case well I need your support I don't
need you to have a packing party I don't
need you to become a minimalist I'm not
gonna come to your home and judge all
the things that you have in your house
you have to clean your house before I
get over there because you think I'm
gonna you know cast some kind of
judgment on your how your home is
organized I was like this is about me
and all I need is your support and
that's that's really what kind of we got
to her heart and really made her
kind of at least understand where I was
coming from and she she she came out to
visit my girlfriend and I in Montana
last February was the first time she'd
had come out to Montana and we pick her
up at the airport we get back to our
place she opens up her suitcase and like
the first thing she does is pull out
like this owl vase and like a couple
candle holders and like I think was like
oh [ __ ] man I gotta make a trip to the
goodwill or something like but I'm not
gonna be rude or right like I was
totally not going to be angry at her for
getting me these gifts before I could
even really like process all that she
was like hey you know I just want to let
you know that you're really doing an
amazing job with your life and I am so
proud of you and I'm so happy to be out
here in Montana and I know you guys just
moved in a couple months ago and I just
really wanted to get you these items to
show you how much I appreciated you and
to show you how much how much I love you
and I totally understand if these items
don't fit in your home and she was like
if you need to give them away or you
need to donate them that's totally okay
with me but but I just wanted to show
you my token of appreciation it took her
four years to get to that point and and
ultimately it was it was living by
example and it was constantly
encouraging her and I mean you know
especially when you call yourselves the
minimalist like everything steeped in
irony and you become the butt of a lot
of jokes so when I would go and you hang
out a family events you know they're
always like giving me a hard time about
stuff and I never like got defensive or
anything it was just kind of I
understood that they were really kind of
projecting this judgment that they
thought I was casting on them but but
not only her but my friends and some
some of my other family members have
totally come around full circle to you
know what are you doing you're crazy -
wow I can't believe what you've done
over the last four years and the changes
that you've made and the different
person that you are and all I did was
was ask for some support and all I did
was support the people I loved
and that's really I think what what I
could encourage you to do with your
family and I think if there was a
magical answer it I certainly haven't
found it yet but I can tell you this
there are a few things I've learned is
don't try to prove other people wrong
especially the people that you care
about which is really hard for me
because I am right all the time and so
when other people aren't right
they think you're joking and I find this
with my partner Becca you know she
thinks she's right all the time and
she's pretty confident about it and and
what I've realized is that my first
reaction is to say my way of living of
thought process whatever is the right
way and often there are several right
ways and and what I've learned is that
the people closest to me we tend to have
similar values but we often have
radically different beliefs so the value
is sort of the destination the values
where you're going the belief is the
path but how you're going to get there
if you look at me and Ryan we have
nearly identical values and we have
appreciably different beliefs we don't
believe the same things about religion
we don't believe certainly don't believe
the same things about politics that's
all we're not going to be talking about
that at all tonight and and we we don't
have the same personalities either I
mean if you put us on a myers-briggs
test we're exact opposites he is an
extrovert extreme extrovert I am an
extreme introvert
he is a DD I'm OCD but it works out well
because we have similar values and my
guess is your marriage works really well
because you have the same values you
have these different beliefs templates
on how you're going to get there though
and and what I can tell you is there are
some resources I'll point you toward
because it's not an easy answer so a few
things one is Patrick Rowan who was in
here in the documentary he he wrote a
book called enough but he writes a lot
about
his relationship and his he's in a very
similar situation he's he is an ultra
minimalist himself but his wife and and
their daughter not so much we went to go
film them in in Minnesota and he's like
constantly moving stuff out of the way
that's not mine that's not mine this
isn't mine and he and I had this great
conversation so the first thing I'd love
to do is after word we'll have some
books out here I'd love to give you a
copy of one of our books it's called
essential and there's an essay in there
about understanding other people and it
was based on a conversation I had with
Patrick when we were filming this and
and basically I realized that these four
stages of getting to understand people
who are closest to us and I'll just walk
through those really quickly but the
first one there's an acronym for it -
Tara t-ara the first step is tolerance
being able to tolerate that person right
so that you're not going in and trying
to get rid of their stuff because I can
identify with you because that's the
first thing I would want to do I
identify the problem and I'm going to
solve it immediately and by the way it's
so much easier to get rid of other
people's stuff it was and so so when
Ryan had his packing party when he was
getting rid of his stuff he's boxing all
up after the 21-day experiment that he
did where he got rid of everything and
he was trying to figure out there are
some things I'm gonna hold on to
afterward he had me come over and I'm
just like I've got trash bags I'm
sweeping stuff into it like this is gone
donate it gone he's like wait I'm gonna
need that just in case and that's
because it's much easier for us to get
rid of other people's stuff but the
truth is that especially if there are
things in there they have some sort of
attachment to it for whatever reason
they've associated a meaning to the
thing well we were just going to
tolerate that first now I'll tell you
this tolerance is a weak hurt you and it
will not strengthen your relationship
long term but it's a first step and it's
a decent first step so if you just
tolerate someone your eventually over
time you're going to feel some sort of
anxiety in the situation or worse and so
tolerance is a good first step
tolerating whatever the be
unless it's a bad behavior someone's
doing something that's harmful to
themselves or others like literally
harmful then that's different right but
you know we'll tolerate the behavior is
the first step and then we go from there
to acceptance so accepting them for who
they are quirks and all it doesn't mean
they won't change over time and you
can't you can still show them the better
way of living through your perspective
but accepting that man is difficult
accepting the person for who they are
and and the next step is the R which is
respect so we take this huge leap from
tolerance tolerating the behavior to
okay I can finally accept this I'm not
just putting up with it this is how it
is right now no it's always now no
matter when it is
there is only now and it can change in
the future but I'm going to accept it in
the now and then when I learned from
Patrick and his wife is he respects what
his wife brings she's a collector of
things by the way if you look up collect
in a thesaurus the first definition next
to it is hoard this is this is not my
definition this is your dictionary so so
collecting to me is hoarding but to
other people they find it meaningful
they find value in it right and so being
able to accept that okay just because I
don't find value and it doesn't mean
that someone else won't okay I can
accept that oh they actually find value
they do enjoy this for some reason I can
respect that and the last step which is
almost like transcendence it's really
hard to get to because it's somewhere
far away from where we are typically is
appreciation being able to appreciate
that person for who they are including
that thing that we see is a flaw and an
overtime by displaying the positive
benefits of simplifying and I hesitate
to use the word minimalism because
sometimes it can have a negative
connotation to someone like that for
people who want to make a change they
hear minimalism they're like yeah I want
to do that but for people who
our defensive you know maybe it's just
about being intentional with what we
bring into our lives and so intentional
ISM might be the better word for some of
those people and so if you're able to
truly appreciate where they are I think
you can grow together and so I'll give
you that book but but cuz I don't want
to feel like I'm selling you a book so
I'm gonna give it to you afterward but I
would also recommend to other resources
one if you go to the minimalists comm
slash children there's an essay there
and a book the essay is by Leo Bob alte
who is in the film and he we asked him
to write this essay it's called no
excuses minimalism with six kids and all
six of his kids and his wife Eva have
radically different personalities and
they make it work
and the other the book that I'm gonna
recommend is a book called clutter free
with kids which he saw a Joshua Becker
in in the film and he just had a new
book come out this week which I really
like there's a bunch of other recipes
for minimalism and book form it's called
the more of less so I would recommend
those and reading those will give you a
better that's your homework it's not not
your wife's homework but it's your
homework and I think they'll give you a
better perspective and it will allow you
to change over time and and you'll find
people following at least in your
direction thank you
thanks so much thank you let's do we're
gonna do one more before before we close
it out here yes ma'am
hi howdy how are you Karen Florida
native and I have to say you guys are an
inspiration
um as a lifelong consumer myself and
busy person it's hard like it's really
hard so I recently got married and my
husband moved in to where I was living
so we have two of everything so we're
trying to curate everything and you know
pick the best one we don't need 28
spoons right so we'll get rid of half of
them but I mean the people at Goodwill
know me now like i drop off stuff
they're like hi how are ya but I just
it's like I I'm not making a dent like I
just I feel like so much stuff like
maybe I am a hoarder but I feel like
it's not like it's very hard and you see
the benefits of relationship and even
you know your impact on the environment
and your health and all of that so it's
great stuff but it's like getting there
I know it's not an end point but even
feeling the progress I think is a
challenge do you have any what what
types of things in particular are a
challenge you I mean you mentioned the
28 spoons and well is there paper
clutter is there photographs I mean
photographs books
my husband has 500 DVDs and CDs he's a
music fan which is wonderful he had all
the CD cases like all of them in the
plastic thing I convinced him to keep
the CDs but put him in just one of those
books they won that battle that was
great
so now I'm working on the it's just so
much things like there's nothing wrong
with them cuz yeah we can watch a movie
whenever we want and he has very varied
music taste but it's just so much stuff
and and books and just a lot of things
and you feel like you can't like get out
from under it like I literally probably
go every two weeks and donate stuff I
wanted to have a garage sale but I was
like there's no I just can't
like I can't this is too much things you
know so I just donate it all it's a
great book title
there's too much things my last year I
became a parent by proxy and my
partner's two and a half year old has a
Twitter account and she tweets things
like there's too much things all the
time now you know I'm gonna give you a
few sort of practical tips but I'll also
say I also challenge you to question the
value of the things that you're holding
on to I mean I don't know how one even
plays a CD anymore what when I was going
through my my stuff
I found a hoard of VHS tapes and there's
a reason people don't laugh because they
all have them and it's okay I'm not
judging I'm simply identifying with you
I
the average American household has
300,000 items I had more than that and
and I was an organized hoarder though
right because I had an ordinal system of
bins and boxes and and I was able to
hide my clutter by organizing and so I
think that organizing is a dangerous
word when we we misunderstand it I think
the professional organizers understand
that well when there's a professional
organizer they hope you actually get rid
of your stuff because the best way to
organize your stuff is to get rid of
most of it right and so so what where
you are right now is you've merged homes
congratulations on the marriage by the
way and congratulations on getting that
step together it's okay to clap
and and so now you're actually at a
really good point cuz it sounds like
you're both on the same page in terms of
we both want to get to a more simplified
version of where we are and that may
look different slightly different for
both of you and I think that's okay
so a few things for you to try because
you have a lot of stuff and it's kind of
hard to know where to get started
because you're like is it DVDs is the
books is it spoons and I would recommend
something called the 30-day minimalism
game are you familiar with that yeah
okay you just started it okay beautiful
day six okay so it starts out really
easy right because so for those of you
who don't know what the 30-day
minimalism game is you can find the
details of it at the minimalists comm
slash game but we've literally had tens
of thousands of people play it there's a
hashtag you can look at a bunch of
people's photos online and stuff and
basically it works out you just grab a
friend or a family member or co-worker
someone who else who wants to simplify
their life and you start at the
beginning of a month so the first day of
the month you each get rid of one item
second day of the month two items third
day the month three items starts out
really easy gets you that momentum you
need to get started and to keep going
but by mid month it's much more
difficult by day 15 you're like okay 15
items day 16 Oh 16 items day 25 25 items
day 26 26 I'd and all of a sudden it's
it's more difficult now whoever goes the
farthest wins if you both make it to the
end of the month you both won because
you've both gotten rid of about 500
items which usually puts a big dent and
and gives you that inertia at that point
because you asked that question so many
times does this add value to my life
does this add value why do I have so
many spoons what are all these doilies
are these your doilies are my doilies
and and you're at a point where you're
like okay I can let go of this and then
you start asking questions how is this
the best way for me to own this because
we're moving from a a culture of
ownership to a culture of access no
longer do I have to have the 2000 CDs
that I once had they're in my pocket now
no longer do I have to have the 500 or
so DVDs that I had that they're on
Netflix right and or wherever I want to
get movies and and I no longer need to
own the physical artifact in order to
have access to the things that I enjoy
and so the next question would be after
you you're playing the old minimalism
game you think it's fun and you're
enjoying letting go because I think
decluttering is kind of boring that's
all we came up with the game to make a
little bit more fun with friendly
competition but but you'll start asking
other questions too what do I have
access to and then it gets easier and
once you realize that if I let go of
this it's okay I'm not gonna miss it the
memories aren't in the things the
memories are in us and these things are
weighing me down their anchors they're
in the way you get the excess out of the
way you start to realize that the things
you're holding on to they do add value
to your life and you start enjoying the
things you own a lot more and that's the
paradox of minimalism as a minimalist
everything I own serves a purpose or it
brings me joy and everything else is out
of the way so so whether it's my my
clothes or my car or my kitchen where it
all has a function or I really enjoy
having it like a piece of artwork and
the other stuff I no longer attach
meaning to the things and so a couple
basic rules that the Ryan I have set up
twenty twenty rules some of you may know
about this that we call the just-in-case
rule Ryan and I found that we were
holding on to a lot of stuff just in
case I needed it someday in some
non-existent hypothetical future and
this rule let me let go of the thousands
if not tens of thousands of just in case
I have all those things in the junk
drawers and and the big oversized orange
sweatshirt with tassels that I was going
to wear one day you know whatever it may
be
these things that I was going to wear
even though I didn't love I let go of it
I wasn't gonna hold on to any more just
in case and and the twenty twenty rule
for that is anything I I let go of just
in case I can get it back less than $20
less than twenty minutes from where
I am let me tell you that rule has
worked for us a hundred percent of the
time now you might say well yeah but I
want to spend hundreds of dollars
replacing my stuff that's crazy it's
wasteful between the two of us we've
written about this over the last five
years we've had to use that rule five
times between the two of us so a hundred
dollars that's 50 bucks each that's ten
dollars a year it's less than a dollar a
month allows me to it sounds like an
infomercial for less than a dollar a
month you too can help with starving
minimalist no less than a dollar a month
it's let me let go of tens of thousands
of items that are no longer in the way
for me so 2020 rule is a nice one and
and and then the 9090 rule is one that
will help me let go of a lot of of
things that I'm like have I used this in
the last 90 days am I going to use it in
the next 90 days and be honest with
yourself about that right because if I
haven't used in the last 90 and I'm not
gonna use it in the next 90 that
accounts for seasonality when I when I
went to my mother's house after she
passed I was going through all her stuff
and there was a lot of excess stuff but
I found 14 winter coats in her in her
bedroom closet 14 now she lived in st.
Pete Beach she didn't need 14 with their
coat so I'm still had the tags on and I
realized that she was holding onto a lot
of those things just in case and that 90
90 rule would have certainly helped out
a lot and so have you used in the last
90 days are you gonna use it next 90 and
the last thing I recommend is experiment
a lot experiment with things that you
think you need and temporarily deprive
yourself of those things I'll do these
little stoical experiments from time to
time where I got rid of the internet for
a month at home no internet at home so I
had to go somewhere to go on the
internet it was most productive month of
my life it was no longer lost in the
Bermuda Triangle of Facebook and YouTube
and Instagram or whatever and I never
got it back that was five years ago
now I'm not prescribing that to you I'm
not saying you should get rid of your
internet
what I'm saying is be willing to be
uncomfortable for a bit to see if
something really adds value to your life
or not I got rid of my cell phone for
two months and I realized I was
depriving myself of it but I could also
bring it back into my life and use it in
a different way no longer do I have
facebook or email on my phone but I have
in my life to send text messages or to
get music or directions or podcasts or
maybe even make a phone call and so I
realized you can use these things
differently as well so be willing to
experiment I'll also give you a copy of
everything that remains afterward
because I wrote about a bunch of little
experiments I did in the 8th chapter of
that book I think you'll find some value
in some of those experiments one thing
you said that really stood out to me was
you said it's really hard and I think
it's too often we confuse simple with
easy simple is not easy I think it's
easy to horde I think it's easier to go
out and buy stuff I think it's easier to
not live that simple life so um I would
say that yes it is gonna take a lot of
effort but I think you're doing a great
job I mean if you're going to Goodwill
every two weeks and you're playing and
you're playing the men's game and
getting rid of stuff on a regular basis
it may not feel like you're making a
dent but if you continue to do that
stuff I promise you
it may take a year it may take two years
but if you continue to incorporate those
habits into your life I promise you one
day you will look at your home I go oh
my God where all this stuff go and uh
just keep up the good work don't be too
hard on yourself I mean if you really
want to like just get rid of everything
and you know do it in a month you could
always do the packing party like I did
and pack everything up but it sounds
like that's that's a little bit too
extreme for you um you might you might
want to start maybe start in one room or
starting like a you know the the
bathroom closet maybe just start with a
packing party there and just kind of
take it in and bite sizes but honestly
it sounds like you're doing exactly what
you need to be doing you're asking the
right questions you're taking a lot of
action just keep up the good work thank
you thank you yes sir one last question
here
I don't know if this is a question but
more about confession I'll set up the
booth hi I'm Ryan Nicodemus and I'm a
minimalist product designer so it's
coming from the opposite end of the
spectrum and my girlfriend kind of sort
of surprised me on this event so I'm the
one that's probably one of the causes of
some of these issues that people are
having and throughout my career and my
journey throughout my product design
journey 15 years it really has given me
the opportunity to look inward and
really understand why these things are
manifesting and throughout my career
I've been just downsizing myself and
realizing you really don't need the
beautiful spoon I mean it industrial
design is intended for purpose and it
has a essence of utilitarianism and the
correct the problem that people are
having but at the same time people start
focusing on more on the beauty and the
warmth and the kind of like to attain
more things so my question is is that
are you guys planning on possibly
infiltrating industrial design schools
of any sort and maybe that might be a
good perspective for our industrial
designers to think about as they are
going through using less less waste
reusables and things like that as it is
a major topic but what are you guys
proposing maybe in the future somebody
asked what are you guys doing in the
future and I'm just kind of like opening
that up for you guys you know so you say
you you might be part of the problem I
could say I certainly was so at the
zenith of my my corporate career I was
the director for a hundred and fifty
retail stores which yeah which yeah I
know it's really ironic with the whole
minimalism thing and
retail and but but the truth is that
that yes that wasn't necessarily in line
with my values as a person I'm not
saying there's anything inherently wrong
with a retail store especially a well
done brick and mortar shop Ryan and I
recently earlier this year back in
January we opened a coffee shop
with some friends of ours up in st.
Petersburg Florida called Bandar coffee
and that was a very deliberate decision
and it was a place to create a spot for
community there where there was sort of
a void and also to educate people on
coffee but also do so in a very
responsible way so it sounds to me like
what you're talking about is is
responsible design and I think what
needs to happen because I think
aesthetics are important for several
reasons one is is your beauty as part of
the joy of life but you're right I think
that the forum does need to follow
functionality and we get caught up in
this trap of of going after the forum
and losing function or caring less about
the function is that we start focusing
more on the beauty and then forgetting
what we're really what that phone is
supposed to be doing or whatever that
piece of furniture is supposed to be
doing you're supposed to sit on it but
you know you lose the whole essence of
what it's supposed to do yeah yeah I
think it's a great idea to bring that to
to the forefront of design I think there
are a lot of people out there that are
doing it now the question is how how can
you do it on a grand scale I think we
tend to vote with our wallets and buying
high-end goods is okay if two things
happen one I can afford it and B it's
going to add value in some way no and I
mean afford it I don't mean just
financially afford something I mean is
this the right decision for the
environment can I afford the space can I
afford the attention can I afford what
this is
to bring to my life and also what it's
going to do to the world around me it's
not just about me but the affording
piece is expansive piece the other side
of that is is is it going to add value
is this the best use of this resource
and I find now quite often what I'll do
is I buy things used and even higher and
things used I mean you saw Julia sure in
here talk about clothing and how
clothing now cost less than rice and
beans per pound high-end gently used
clothing you know that you would spend
normally spend hundreds of dollars for
you know whatever the new Kanye West
t-shirt or something you you you you now
can buy you know the functional
equivalent to that for less than you can
buy food and it's backwards and so I
found a way to break that cycle is you
could buy a lot of things use you could
buy high-end things use you can
repurpose things now whether or not we
can bring that to two design schools or
whatever I don't know I think it's a
phenomenal idea and and I certainly
would put that on the bank of things I
would consider folks you know because I
think it's meaningful it's a blog idea
for you man this new concept I guess for
me it's not very new because I've seen
the progression of where everyone is
going and this is chaotic when you're
just consuming for the purpose of
consuming like I guess it goes back to
and hearing hunting-and-gathering you
know and we're just gathering things for
the purpose of gathering thanks a lot
thank you
so afterward we'll be out here we'll
form a line here before you do that I
want to thank some folks if you want to
grab a hug afterward as you saw they are
available and we encourage you to pass
them on so we'll form a line that way
out there and we're gonna like go around
and we'll be out in the lobby we also
have some books out there if you
purchase a book tonight a hundred
percent of the proceeds go to our
favorite charity
it's the Josh and Ryan gasps fun to get
to Dallas they do great work no
seriously if you didn't bring a wall or
you can't afford a book or whatever
don't worry it's on us here you can take
a book if you'd like or you can pay
whatever you want that's really our
model you pay whatever you want or you
could just take a book we're happy to
give you one and I want to thank a few
people Sean is around here somewhere so
we have a guy named Sean Harding who is
is he here there he is he is sort of
everything behind the minimalist he does
he produces our podcasts he does our
road manager our tour manager he edits
our books he does everything for the
minimalist he is the hardest-working man
and minimalism ladies and gentlemen
let's give him a round of applause
oh thank you I appreciate that and being
backstage I want to give a quick thank
you to the folks here at the at the
Quebec Center Theatre will up there in
the booth who is doing all the audio and
video thank you so much will I will
appreciate your help Elena Perez is back
here in the back with the Quebec t-spin
so thank you so very much I think some
of the folks backstage thank you
so also we it's really expensive for us
to go on tour so the company that hosts
our website so we started this blog like
six years ago and we could not even
spell blog at the time we actually
literally didn't know it was called a
blog we call it a website and we later
found out what a blog was and and so
I've initialized arted out by trying to
like do HTML coding and I was reading a
book and I'm like I have no idea what
the hell I'm doing it I remember one day
I called Ryan up and I'm like forget it
man this is done I cannot do this and
he's like what's wrong and we figured
out what something called WordPress was
and then this company called Bluehost
really helped us out you know and
they've been really supportive of this
whole movement and they've been plant
paying for a lot of our travels on this
tour and they are not asking for
anything from us but I just want to say
thanks to them so you give them a round
of applause either live together
if if you want to see the the film in
your area you can set up your own
screening locally you can just go to
minimalism film comm and click on see
the film and you can host the screen in
your area or there may be one at a local
theater near you it comes out May 24th
in about 400 theaters across the United
States so if you have a local theater
you can always set one up there as well
and it's gonna be the the movie captain
in your area and most important I just
want to thank you for being here tonight
and we'll see you after this come grab a
hug but if you leave here with just one
message I hope it's this love people and
use things because the opposite never
works thanks so much
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your green you know I bet that you'll be
fine without every little thing that you
gotta have every little thing that you
got you gotta reach for and you got a
grand oh I bet that you'll be fine
without you
so tear your eyes or two
me
you